i am only now sharing my story because i
want other women to feel supported and
loved whether
they want to share their own
or not ireland baldwin opening up about
her own experiences with rape and
abortion
following the supreme court's decision
to overturn the landmark roe v wade
ruling last week triggering laws making
abortion illegal in several states
across the nation
before i share what i'm going to share
i don't feel that it is anybody's
responsibility to talk about this if
they don't feel comfortable the 26 year
old shared two very personal stories on
tick tock hoping to help other women
feel supported after friday's ruling
i want to have a voice for good and i
want to do something i want to stand for
something and help people
and you know people aren't going to like
me and that's fine and i understand that
she also makes it a point to say that no
one should feel pressured to tell their
story but she's ready to tell hers
i'm not here to tell this story today
but i was raped when i was a teenager
and i was completely unconscious when it
happened
and it changed the course of the rest of
my life
i never told anyone at the time not for
years the only person who knew was a
nurse that treated me shortly after
and i didn't even tell my own boyfriend
at the time
not my parents no one i just think a lot
of people get shamed for
being who they are and there's nothing
wrong with being who you are ireland
says the guilt and shame that came with
keeping that a secret led to her
spiraling and losing control
i drank a lot more i partied a lot more
i self-medicated
i was in
other abusive and toxic relationships
and friendships
i pretty much just did everything i
could to distract myself
seeing so many other brave women share
their stories
got me thinking what my life would have
been like if i had become pregnant
and if i had to raise a baby
during everything i was going through at
the time
ireland admits that even under those
trying circumstances
she still had medical resources money
and support
that a lot of women don't have access to
but those privileges still wouldn't have
taken away how quote traumatizing and
impossible it would have been for her to
raise a baby at that time
flash forward to another point in my
life when i did have a boyfriend and i
did become pregnant
ireland then goes on to recall a time
when she did get pregnant and decided to
undergo an abortion
at that point in time i would say we
were very unhappy together and
he made it pretty clear that he never
wanted kids or marriage um he barely
wanted to be in a serious relationship
that toxicity led to ireland choosing to
terminate her pregnancy because as she
puts it she knows exactly what it felt
like to be born between two people that
hated each other
referring to the tumultuous marriage
between her parents alec baldwin and kim
basinger i've had so many people help me
through that time in my life and i think
it's really important to share what i've
learned you know could i have had that
baby and put that baby up for adoption
maybe maybe not
but choosing to raise a baby without my
own financial security
without a loving and supportive partner
that wasn't going to work for me
i chose me and i would choose me again
it's your life it's your choice